the crane and Company guys broke this
story a couple of days ago I meant to
get to it yesterday fortunately we're
able to get to it today
the story is from this interview with
one of Leah Thomas's teammates Leah
Thomas is actually named will Thomas
he's that hulking dude who swam on the
UPenn women's swim team and then beat
all the girls and took their trophies
and he's just obviously a big guy but he
pretends to be a woman and so we've all
got to pretend that he's a girl and he's
smashing the glass ceiling and it's so
wonderful and brave and stunning
so one of will Thomas's teammates comes
out and gives a great interview which I
strongly recommend you go check out at
cranny company
where she says man this is gross this
guy showed up to the locker room he
strips down naked all of us girls had to
be subjected to looking at him back when
he still had the male parts
and then she spilled a little bit more
tea
the part that everyone is focusing on
from this interview is that uh will
Thomas's
boyfriend it's a boy who thinks that
he's a girl I don't know
will Thomas's paramour uh was
photographed holding up a a jar
with what appeared to be pickle juice
and then two
spherical objects in
the the jar
so at two I don't think they were olives
I don't think they were little onions
that you put in the cocktails okay
so
that was what everyone was focusing on
in this interview with with one of
Will's competitors I misspoke not one of
his teammates one of his competitors
and uh there's something more
interesting about the interview though
and the pictures that were uncovered and
the details about will Thomas's personal
life
there's a bunch of weird satanic stuff
there's a bunch of really weird sexual
stuff that was if not posted by Will
Thomas at least liked by Will Thomas on
Instagram things that talked about Auto
gynophilia auto gynophilia is one of the
explanations for transgenderism there
there are within I was going to say
historically but because the whole
phenomenon is so modern
there have been proposed in recent
decades two types of transgenderism
homosexual men who view themselves as
women and also men who are sexually
aroused by the thought of them having
female genitals and that's called
autogonophilia
so will Thomas seems to have liked
uh some of these posts about auto gun
affiliate which might suggest that
uh will Thomas will Thomas's identity is
is
a little weirder
is is a little more sexual in nature but
then what I find even more interesting
than that is
all the weird satanic imagery so
one post liked by Will Thomas
jokes that will will bring about the
quote collapse of Western Civilization
another one is a picture of Will as a
demonic dominatrix character
uh there are posts that refer to will
Thomas as being in a follicule that's a
group of sexually confused people who
all do weird stuff with one another
uh in fact the person who wrote nice
follicule is a is a user named crybaby
hell
uh
Beyond uh crybaby hell there's
another uh transgender identifying
person who has photos in a very
sexualized abusive kind of fetishistic
way
uh the Gory and stunning as one
commenter writes and so I'm not making
any particular
claims about will Thomas or any of will
Thomas's friends or
friends with benefits or more than
friends
I just can't help but notice something
that I've noticed for a long time
it's always the same imagery
it's always it always gets back to weird
devil demonic horns and Tails and
pitchforks kind of imagery I made this
point at the Grammys when Sam Smith got
on stage dressed like a lesbian Lucifer
and jiggled around with a bunch of
androgynous transsexual looking people
and the the clip ended up going viral
because my publicists over at Media
Matters were very shocked and offended
that I made the point that very often
depictions of the Demonic are quite
androgynous or trans and depictions of
transgenderism and androgyny are quite
often demonic
which is just true
so when Media Matters posted it I just
retweeted it I thought yeah that's very
true what a great point I made
it's always this kind of imagery isn't
it isn't that a little bit
odd
isn't that a little bit weird it's
almost as though
you can't really separate the physical
from the metaphysical it's almost as
though symbols matter and so the reason
that that people with these weird sexual
desires keep going back to the same
symbolism the same symbols that we've
seen all the way back to Antiquity with
the bad guy the little bad Red Demon
with the horns and the Pitchfork and the
tail and the fangs and the goatee and
whatever all of these symbols is because
they might actually represent something
why do we talk about people who struggle
with these kinds of psychological
problems as having demons
today we think that we're just speaking
metaphorically oh it's just a metaphor
it's it's a metaphor for chemicals going
off in their brains
well I don't even know what that means I
mean if we're talking about metaphor
we're talking about something beyond the
physical world but all of us I don't
care how hardened a materialist you are
you behave as though there is something
beyond the material world you believe
you behave as though there is some kind
of moral order you behave as though
there are things that are immaterial
that still matter like loves and joys
and Mathematics and out of all the
intangible things that you can't quite
touch or smell or see but nevertheless
you know are there and you know those
things are often represented by physical
objects
we all behave that way and so I just
think we need to pay a little more
attention to symbols I mentioned at the
top of the show that I'm not a
conspiracy theorist at all I'm actually
rather grounded and always seek a
rational explanation when when one is
available to me but I also can't help
but notice things and I find that's
especially true when we're talking about
symbols
the modern world refuses to acknowledge
symbols in fact it explicitly denies
symbolism because it in its thought if
not in its Behavior it tries to deny
that there's any metaphysical reality
beneath the physical world
but for Christians or Jews or Muslims or
or even pagans or anybody with any even
quasi-traditional understanding of
religion and man's place in the universe
there is no such thing really as
coincidence
there is a broader Providence there is
there is meaning okay so if you believe
that there is meaning
then there has got to be meaning to the
fact that all these sexual deviants
keep going back to the same image of
that same old devil
gotta mean
something the rest of the show continues
now
you do not want to miss a go to
dailywear.com Knowles use code Knowles
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]